but at this point with so much already
invested in Ukraine withdrawing support
is easier said than done I just came up
with that
president DeSantis might be able to do
what no Biden can do pull out in time
horrible
I'm Dave Rubin it's March 20th 2023.
it's a Monday we're live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals share
subscribe tap the notification Bell if
you have not and if you want to join us
for the post game show subscribe over at
reubenreport.locals.com important note
internal note before we do anything on
the program today we have a new person
in studio today as you guys know we
brought Brock on board about what now
six months ago it's been a while you've
been nearly three months ago time's fine
I've lost all sense of time with the
children but he has now moved along with
his fiance to the free state of Florida
they moved to Miami they don't have uh
any uh you have no bed you have no couch
yet none of that stuff but more good
people moving to Florida it's happening
people the mass migration people leaving
other places coming to live free you're
welcome Ron DeSantis I think I got you
two more voters
um we have a big show today the uh this
Trump Fiasco out of New York obviously
is the big thing that everybody's
talking about that this Soros funded
district attorney is going after Trump
on a 2016 charge for paying off a
prostitute or a porn star whatever she
was we'll get into some of that stuff
but first I had I saw this over the
weekend and we have to address something
very very important uh this is from
afru.com which I'm told is some sort of
black Website Magazine uh where they
tell black people what they're supposed
to think and you can see they have a
very important piece here is coffee
racist how drinking coffee perpetuates
white supremacy created by black people
for black people and now a pillar of
white supremacist capitalism if you
consume coffee you're helping an
industry built on racism before I
comment let me just have a little bit of
this delicious white supremacist coffee
that I keep in our official Reuben
report mug which you can buy by the way
at our white supremacist store just go
to reubenreport.com you'll find out how
you can do that
you know it is funny I wake up in the
morning before I have coffee and I feel
that everyone should be treated equally
you know what I mean I really do that's
my initial thought I take the blanket
off walk over to the sink brushing my
teeth and I'm always thinking like
everyone should be treated equally
we shouldn't have racism or bigotry or
any of those things then I have my
coffee and I start feeling this thing
you know that feeling that caffeine
gives you and you're like no there
should be separate water fountains for
certain people
oh the idiocy never ends anyway we're
going to be talking about the machine
today because I think a lot of people
are waking up right like this is an
ongoing thing people are always waking
up and a certain amount of people are
always going to Slumber but I think what
happened over the weekend is is really
really important because I noted that
even some of the types of people that
generally don't wake up to things are
kind of like wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute they're going after Trump
and going to arrest Trump I mean Trump
on Truth social he posted a message they
are going to arrest him tomorrow Tuesday
that's what he's saying he has slightly
backtracked it since and it's a little
unclear if this is going to happen but
anyone in their right mind knows after
17 impeachments and January 6 nonsense
and everything else that is this is just
an endless Witch Hunt because the guy is
running for president so whether you
support Trump or not whether you're a
Republican or not or a conservative or
not whether you like DeSantis or Nikki
Haley or anyone else whether you're a
lifelong Democrat
you should be looking at this and going
this is Banana Republic level stuff when
we have prosecutors in States going
after people for nonsensical things and
we'll get into the nonsense uh in a bit
uh this is Witch Hunt it's as simple as
that and uh and people are coming out
and actually saying it and I'm seeing
even like even pretty NPC type people
non-playable character type people are
actually waking up to some of this so
that's what we're going to be talking
about today how the machine in essence
will go after anyone who descends and
why really you have to be brave within
that because your choices all right
don't be brave and just have the machine
swallow you whole and many many people
are waking up uh whether it's Joe Rogan
whether it's Tulsi gabbard or Rod
DeSantis is leading it here in Florida
now trying to export it and As Trump has
said many times they're not coming after
me they're coming after you I'm just
standing in the way and I think he's
quite right about that and now that we
have set it up let me talk about Patriot
Supply and then we'll get to it guys
anyone who thinks they won't need
emergency food isn't paying attention
every day the headlines get worse and
worse is the unthinkable next it pays to
prepare that's why I seriously recommend
you stock up on emergency food right
away you never know when the next shoe
will dry up and when it does emergency
food will be hard to find so get yours
now while it's on sale go to
mypatriotsupply.com and check out their
popular three-month emergency food kit
we've got a couple of them downstairs
right now you'll save 200 per kit each
kit gives you a wide variety of
delicious breakfast lunches dinners
drinks and snacks providing over 2 000
calories a day for Optimum strength and
energy act now and claim your 200
savings per kit you'll sleep better
knowing your family won't suffer if the
worst ever happens zombie apocalypse
cobit 9 Etc go to mypatriotsupply.com
and you'll enjoy free shipping too go to
mypatriotsupply.com and now back to me
okay so again I am going to frame the
show the purpose of the show is to show
you how you must push back and how they
will always keep coming and that will be
sort of directly related to what's going
on with Trump but I didn't want to start
with Trump because there's other
interesting things happening and then
we'll hit Trump uh as we get towards the
end of the show we're going to show you
what the Divide is here okay and I think
you guys see it
I think a lot of other people see it so
let's get right to it uh Joe Rogan who
I'm told is a popular podcaster has a
show on Spotify uh here he is I would
say accurately illustrating the new
political divide in America I think it's
very much in line with some ideas that
I've been pushing and some other people
are pushing but it's good that it's
getting to Joe and he's disseminating it
amongst the millions of people that
listen to him every week
the culture shift between right and left
authoritarianism and now people don't
recognize that the if you just stopped
looking at it in terms of red and blue
look at the actions whether it's War
suppression of free speech a
pharmacological interventions that are
mandatory whatever whatever it is that
used to all be associated with the
authoritative right the authoritarian
right and now those things are being
embraced by the left and I just think
it's a I think it's just an ideology
thing I think we get confused and we
think we're on the right side we're on
the right side and if it's our side of
saying this for sure it's the right
thing to do and no one's critically
thinking about this
how I say the line all the time you
don't have to be a republican but you
can't be a Democrat that is what Joe
Rogan is waking up to right and that's
what many other people are waking up to
who is endlessly driving us towards War
right now it's fully the Democrat Party
from Biden on down now there are plenty
of Republicans who are all about this
thing Lindsey Graham uh Mitt Romney
there are plenty of Republicans finding
it but there's plenty of them that are
speaking out against it Thomas Massey
Rand Paul Ted Cruz Marco Rubio and
others so there is a a Divergence there
okay so that's one thing we certainly
know the difference when it comes to
left right or republican Democrat when
it when we're talking about covet and
who locked down and who had the most
Draconian laws and do I have to go into
the crime thing and the drugs and all of
the stuff and then of course look at the
migrations so really what we're seeing
here is the old left right doesn't fully
make sense the Democratic party of today
has nothing to do with the Democrat
Party of say 1985 or even 1967 and
really what we have and I would say the
only lines that you should be thinking
about when you're voting are are you
voting for someone with authoritarian
Tendencies or Freedom Tendencies right
like I don't expect the government to do
that much I don't want the government to
do that much I think the biggest problem
we have right now is that everyone
thinks the government's supposed to do
everything for them and if it could just
take a little more from those people and
do more for me that things would be good
until you're the guy it's taken from
then you're not so thrilled about it
right so the point here is you you have
limited choices within the system that
we have I would say our system is better
than any other system but it's still a
man-made system it ain't perfect but
within that system you should always be
going to the people who want less to do
with your life who will only use
government in the moments that
government must be used to push
authoritarianism away not the ones who
are constantly trying to give you things
and tell you how to live I'm glad to see
Rogan's waking up to that you know Rogue
again as far as I know he did not vote
in the last election but he has said
that he would vote for DeSantis so that
is good you know to me I don't know how
he couldn't see that obviously you had
to vote for Trump last time because
Biden was going to give us exactly what
he did but but better late than never
right it's why I'm always pushing Bill
Maher better late than never for that
set of people who still can be swayed
because you might be tired of listening
to me talk about them but they are the
group that actually could change the
election because they're the ones that
can move most people cannot move but
it's not just Joe Rogan I think the
other really interesting example of this
type of thinking someone who was a
Democrat uh I think her entire life and
served in Congress as a Democrat is
Tulsi gabbard Tulsi gabbard who is the
last Democrat running against Joe Biden
when everyone else cut their deals and
she refused to cut a deal so she's out
of the Democrat Party she has officially
left the Democrat Party she is not a
republican to Joe's point
and to my line on this right you don't
have to be a republican you just can't
be a Democrat she did campaign with an
awful lot of Republicans during the
midterms didn't work out that well uh in
terms of results but she is now out
there and she is out there telling
people what the what the score is what
time it is and the truth when it comes
to who is trying to cancel you who is
trying to crush dissent and who is
trying to silence you take a listen
this is why I so appreciate the the
ethos of this organization
faith family and freedom
this is what should be at the core of
what our policy makers and our lawmakers
our leaders from across both parties
should be driven by
instead we have fanatical ideologues in
the Democratic party who don't believe
in free speech they don't believe in the
Second Amendment they don't believe in
our right to worship
the right that every one of us has to
express ourselves
we see time and time again how they seek
to censor and smear those who dare to
challenge their narrative who dare to
challenge their their ideology and they
do so by working very closely with their
Partners in the mainstream media and in
big Tech and they do so
by labeling our Free Speech as
misinformation
a while like she was a Democrat only two
years ago she was running as a Democrat
Presidential nominee right like that's
what she wanted to be that was the party
that she wanted to be in and now she
says things like faith family and
freedom those are the three F words that
the left and the Democrats are
completely afraid to say it's also
interesting you know I've had tulsion a
couple times including about what was it
two three months ago where I talked to
her about I said you know a lot of my
audience and right-leaning people and
conservatives and Libertarians you know
they really like you the one thing
they're concerned about is your feelings
on the Second Amendment it seems very
obvious to me she's uh evolving on that
and you know you have to give people
room to evolve you know I know I know if
you've believed something for a long
time and let's say it's mostly turned
out to be right uh that you want
everybody to get there the second you
get there but you got to give people
just a chance to think it through work
it through figure out where their
friendships and alliances are RC how the
other side reacts them you got to let it
all happen and it's happening right in
our faces with her so this is really
interesting you've got a guy like Joe
Rogan certainly not a traditional
Republican and I'm not telling you he's
going to be a laminated card carrying
member of the Republican Party obviously
not but after what he just said there is
no chance in high hell he can vote for
Joe Biden nor can he vote for Democrats
he also lives in freaking Texas he lives
in Austin which is the one blue city in
Texas and Austin has turned into a dump
under Democrat leadership so I'm sure he
sees that too so if I sit down with
Rogan again I think I would for sure not
I think I absolutely would say that to
him is there any chance you can vote for
a Democrat going forward now I don't
mean in 10 years when the parties flip
again I mean in right now the way things
are set up if you care about freedom and
you care about free speech and all of
those things you mentioned and it's
fairly obvious he's going to vote for a
republican this time or if he doesn't
vote for Republican this time then I
don't mean to be a dick about it but
then people should just stop listening
to him it would be a little bit sort of
like the Bill Maher thing like at some
point you fight these things long enough
and if you always vote the wrong way
then people should just be like okay
what what are we really doing here
um but what happens what happens when
you challenge the machine well we know
remember there were a couple weeks where
every day on CNN they were leading with
Joe Rogan's a white supremacist because
he said the n-word even though it was
not to be pejorative he was making fun
of people that say it what happens to
someone like Tulsi gabbard when you go
against the DNC well you get Hillary
Clinton saying you're a Russian spy and
of course what you know is that the
machine and all of the paid activists of
the machine whether it's Stephen Colbert
or Jimmy Kimmel The Usual Suspects they
will go after you and try to destroy you
because they live only in service of the
machine we're going to get to that in
one sec let me talk to you guys about
tax Network USA real quick you know if
you owe back taxes or or if you have
unfiled returns don't let the government
take advantage of you tax Network USA is
a Nationwide Tax resolution firm who can
protect your rights and settle your back
taxes in some cases they can even zero
out your ballots they are experts in all
IRS programs and understand tax laws so
you don't have to over the last 14 years
tax Network USA has saved over a billion
in back taxes for their clients the
Biden Administration is going to be
overhauling the IRS so they can Levy
bank accounts garnish wages and Social
Security benefits like never before they
can even seize your property like your
business home or retirement accounts
whether you owe a few thousand or a few
million they can help you even if you
haven't filed in years they can still
help you even if you have a payment
arrangement they can help you they can
even file your yearly return to protect
you from audits call the Patriots at tax
Network USA now or visit
taxnetworkusa.com Dave and now back to
me okay so what does the machine do and
trust me guys this is all going to lead
to the Trump thing because I know
everybody wants to hear my feelings on
that and I was quiet over the weekend
because I don't tweet on the weekend
that's my policy that's what keeps me
saved but what happens
when you call out the Dems what happens
when you call out cancel culture you go
against the cultural norms and all of
those things well we know that the
machine will go after you relentlessly
so because Joe Rogan has been waking up
for quite some time we thought we'd just
go back to this one uh from a couple
months ago this is Rogan uh getting
attacked by Jimmy Kimmel on his
quote-unquote comedy show oh no this
isn't a couple months ago this is
earlier this month this is like two
weeks ago uh Rogan getting attacked by
Jimmy Kimmel just two weeks ago over
vaccines
one of the things Joe Rogan recommended
was Ivermectin here's the thing I don't
get you won't take the vaccine but you
will take Ivermectin I mean that you
know good old Ivermectin
there's a product I can try and by the
way if you're looking for advice from a
former host of The Man Show call me next
time okay because I have a I have a
second opinion on this
you know what he means by that because
the co-host of the man show is Adam
Carolla that's the one who did it with
Jimmy Kimmel and they used to have a
bunch of big boob women jumping up on
trampolines for a half hour that was the
show so I don't know what he means that
Joe Rogan was a host of that thing or
but okay let's just put that aside the
point is
Ivermectin does work you should talk to
your doctor okay fine but they it's not
that they just go after those with a
platform why are they going after Rogan
why did CNN spend those weeks going
after Rogan it was because Rogan was
bigger than CNN it wasn't because they
thought he was racist right you guys all
know that but they will also go after
you if you make a choice in your life
you know I'd prefer not to be injected
with their experimental medication
that's something that I would prefer not
to do or I certainly don't want to be
forced into it they will literally go
after you here is Kimmel in May of 21
going after those who didn't want that
mRNA jab which turns out has a lot of
problems
more than 100 million adults in the
United States are now fully vaccinated
which is good but unfortunately more
than one in four say they are not
planning to get the vaccine ever 26
percent of Americans are planning to
skip the shot altogether which is crazy
to me I get the people are skeptical of
politicians or celebrities telling them
what to do but we should listen to
doctors these are men and women who've
been on the front lines of this thing
risking their lives to save ours and
they're frustrated and who could blame
them if we don't get more people
vaccinated we could see new mutations of
this virus and go through this all over
again so as a public service we asked
some real doctors to offer their best
advice to those who are on the fence
about the vaccine and pay attention just
get the vaccine roll up and get the
vaccine and tell your friend on Facebook
to stick to jewelry
okay
thank you
about those doctors first and there was
more to that clip we cut it for you
because you know it's early in the day
and it's Monday and I know you're a
productive person with things to do
first off those doctors should all be
fired imagine you're a doctor you are
supposed to look at someone's chart
you're supposed to see how old they are
how healthy they are what their family
history is what they eat what they drink
etc etc and then you're supposed to make
recommendations imagine going on a TV
show to blanket tell people that they
should be injected with what we know now
is a vaccine that simply does not work
that the one of the inventors of the
very technology behind mRNA uh Dr Robert
Malone now says is causing a severe
degradation of people's immune systems
okay and it's allowing dormant viruses
to break free but imagine that you would
go on a TV show and just berate people
even in a joking fashion that they
should get vaccinated I am very very
proud to say I am in a room right now
with four other human beings so there's
a total of five of us here I'm not a man
the magician but I put it together
myself no one in this room is vaccinated
and I am fairly certain that there isn't
going to be a mutation coming out of
this room everyone's got no one has an
extra arm or anything we're all doing
all right
these people but you see the point you
see the point if you go against what the
machine wants they will come after you
and they will try to get you fired and
canceled and everything else now again
I'm still linking this all to the Trump
thing right because he's the he's the
sort of standard bearer of going against
the machine but as long as we're doing
Jimmy Kimmel I couldn't do a Jimmy
Kimmel clip without showing you Jimmy
Kimmel in blackface because Jimmy Kimmel
loves blackface
that's going to be a spooky time that's
what Home Alone say government got to
step up and give 102 to keeping them
little green man off this here Earth
because the day them dude stick
something up come alone but that's well
that ain't gonna be no good time for
nobody especially
not only blackface but like that's full
black body when you're going black chest
black arm and then of course you're also
making fun of the way he speaks which
some might be some version of ebonics or
something like that
um that's a pretty racist Jimmy Kimmel
by the way your your ex-girlfriend Sarah
Silverman she's also been in blackface
that must have been what brought you
guys together although she was really
just sleeping with you so she could keep
her career going Emmy who uh let's talk
about an actual uh qualified person who
happens to be black he is our uh Chief
doctor here in Florida Joseph latapo and
as you guys know uh Dr latapo who really
is he's an unbelievably good
communicator and if he was a Democrat or
a lefty everyone in the country would be
knowing his name there would be freaking
statues of this guy but he has released
a couple studies now on what the MRNA
vaccine has done us particularly to
young men related to heart conditions uh
and here he is this is just in the last
couple days talking about the terrible
safety profile of the mRNA vacs
people believe that what is happening
isn't actually happening these vaccines
have a terrible safety profile at this
point the pandemic you know I'm not sure
anyone should be taking them and that's
you know that is the honest truth I
don't think anyone probably should be
taking it they have a terrible safety
course
now there was a study published a few
weeks ago in a journal called Lancet a
great you know a journal that's well
known I should say and and what did
these what these authors show they
showed that after seven months the
protection for infection right it you
know it started I don't know around 70
percent down down down down at seven
months
it it hops onto the other side of the
axis right so it is negative and that
continues and that the magnitude of that
negativity increases over time what does
that mean folks it literally means that
the people who received that vaccine
were more likely to contract covid-19
after seven months than the people who
did not
that is a
fast the CDC or FDA ever said a word
about that
no
of course the CDC nor the FDA has not
said a word about that and as a matter
of fact we showed you a clip on Friday
of bouchi still
Dill repeating the lie that every
celebrity and Democrat politician
repeated for the last two years when
they got coveted post being vaccinated
they all said I have covet again but I
am so thankful to have been vaccinated
because I'm getting lesser covid so make
sure you get vaccinated there is
literally
literally no evidence of that and as
latipo is pointing out right there
there's actually reverse evidence of it
because people are getting sicker not
only the vaccine injuries but put remove
the science for just remove science
let's open up the thing and get through
science and we're on the other side of
science now think about your own life
and your friends your friends who are
vaccinated are they getting sick or more
mine are and my my unvaccinated friends
are not friends family just think about
it in your own life right like they also
want to separate your own experience
from everything else that's why they
always want you to focus on these things
but also the other thing is listen to
the specific specificity that latypus
speak with right like he's actually
telling you he's making a point where
it's so the reverse of what fauci is
doing all the time and that is
interesting and you should make choices
for yourself which is exactly what he's
saying there okay so what do you do if
the machine is just going to keep coming
it just going to relentlessly keep
coming through our political
institutions
our educational institutions our
cultural institutions well at some point
you must push back and this is where
conservatives or right-leaning people or
people who just don't worship at the
altar of government this is where we all
struggle because we want the government
to stay out of our lives but then you
have to I would say in a in an accurate
and pinpoint way decide when the
government should be used so Governor
Ron DeSantis was on Glenn Beck's podcast
last week and I thought his uh this is
just a one-minute explanation of when it
is appropriate to use government and why
we should use it I just thought this was
absolutely spectacular and it explains
why things are working here take a look
look at all these things we're slaying
it all ESG we're slaying that the Dei
stuff critical race Theory we're slaying
that uh we we're creating a model for
really I think what a free Society
should be yes freedom for you to not be
constrained by government all
conservatives have always believed in
that but also freedom for you to live
your life without having the pathologies
of the left imposed upon you correct
from all the other institutions in
society and and maybe that's a woke
Corporation maybe that's Soros funds A
D.A in your community and then this D.A
says he's not enforcing the law putting
you in your family at risk we had a
Soros D.A in Tampa that said he was
going to force the law I removed him
from office and he's litigating but I'm
winning the cases and you know you just
have to recognize that the threats to
Freedom are more than just whether
someone's going to come in and raise
your taxes or or pass a bad piece of
legislation so I think Florida we're
fighting full spectrum I think more
conservatives now across the country are
recognizing that we need to fight
Marta we're fighting full spectrum I
love that line I also like this the
pathologies of the left you remember a
clip it was about a week or so ago that
we showed you from CNBC where Mike Pence
was talking about uh Disney and what
happened here and how DeSantis has taken
away some of their special privileges
and their tax benefits and things and
Mike Pence former VP Mike Pence was like
oh I don't know I'm a limited government
guy I don't want to do that and how I
kept saying like that is such an old
version of republicanism that doesn't
work anymore first off you use the
government to ensure equality and Disney
was being treated better than Sea World
and Gator world and it's comparables
let's say so all we did all DeSantis did
in essence was make things equal that's
number one but the pathologies of the
left keep moving so you can't just sit
back all the time and be like well I'm a
conservative I'm a Libertarian and I'm
just not going to use the government to
do anything as long as my tax rates are
low because it doesn't work they will
literally infect your children's minds
they will affect the bank I mean look
what happened svb they will affect the
bank where you put your money they will
affect literally everything so what the
scientist is doing there is quite good
he's saying hey we are going
to pick the moments to make sure that
people can live their life as they wish
we will use the government in those
effective ways and that is exactly what
we've all been asking for uh he
mentioned the fight against ESG we've
got a tweet here from Florida's voice
multi-state Alliance announced to fight
ESG DeSantis previously promised to form
a compact a compact of states to Target
the business practice so ESG you guys
know about ESG we don't have to do a
full breakdown of it but it's it's the
basic idea that this diversity equity
and inclusion and all of the climate
nonsense and all of the social justice
programs should be somehow built into
all of these companies that that should
be their primary driver rather than
whatever it is that the company is
trying to build or create
Etc uh well now there's going to be a
bunch of states that are going to push
back against it so this this is not only
is this federalism States making
decisions for themselves but now
something beautiful is happening states
are going all right well you know there
are these big corporations we do have
this big federal government we better
find some alliances with other states so
we can really figure out how to work
this together so Tennessee and Texas and
Iowa and Florida and South Dakota will
start figuring out ways and maybe we'll
have alternative banking systems I mean
the the opportunity here is absolutely
endless if you just face the problem
down and you run into that fire you run
into that fire knowing you're going to
get singed you're going to get burned a
little bit but you might save the whole
freaking thing if you do what is right
but not everyone's going to do what's
right here is Biden's education
secretary Miguel Cardona going after
DeSantis for abolishing Dei and as you
know Dei diversity Equity inclusion is
just modern racism it means you will
preference certain people on their race
while punishing others but this is the
policy of our federal government
DeSantis doesn't want anything to do
with it several other red states don't
want anything to do with it but the
Biden Administration is all in on it
Governor DeSantis proposed plans to
defund all diversity equity and
inclusion programs at state colleges and
universities now Rhonda santises seems
like he's positioning himself to run for
president he's going to be a national
player for the next couple years so what
kind of implications do you think that
could have if it spreads to the National
level
not only in Florida but across the
country we really have to pay attention
to what's happening to this overreach to
this division in education
it's not overreach it's not division in
education I want every student as Rhonda
said this once in every freedom American
Freedom loving American wants every
student to be treated the exact same way
regardless of the color of their skin
you and Biden and the rest of you clowns
what you guys want is people to let
certain kids into schools depending on
their skin color then let them into
certain grad schools depending on their
skin color or their gender or their
genitals then to get certain jobs based
on that and then we wonder why nothing
works and trains derail and planes will
crash and doctors won't know what to do
because we will have hired all of the
wrong people for all of the wrong
reasons America was founded on the idea
of individual rights we have passed laws
to stop discrimination right you people
are trying to infect us with that
pathology the pathology of the left
which is nothing more than Power Plus
discrimination you wanted every where
we're trying to get rid of it and as far
as I'm concerned and I think most sane
people are concerned is we must hamper
the federal government as much as
possible and
hopefully you'll move to a state where
you can live amongst people who are more
in line with your values and by the way
I mean that if you're a blue person if
you if you're a crazy blue person uh in
Florida go to California get going give
up more of your tax money live amongst
filth and drugs and crime enjoy
there's the beach too well they don't
even let you go to the beach sometimes
so whatever uh but speaking of crazy
people on the left and there are there
are many many of them uh you may
remember Gretchen Whitmer she is the
governor recently re-elected Governor
because people just love being punished
recently re-elected governor of Michigan
she has a face full of Botox and fillers
which I have no doubt she got while she
was locking people in their houses she
stopped people in Michigan from
gardening during covid she literally
made sure that if you went to Lowe's or
Home Depot they closed the smaller
versions of those stores they kept the
big box ones open but they would shut
down the aisles where you could get uh
seeds and things I actually from crazy
La I sent people in Michigan seeds so
that they could Garden but here is
Gretchen Whitmer who is an expert on
nothing other than being a horrible
person uh talking about desantis's
comments on Ukraine because DeSantis
doesn't want us to be in an endless war
like I don't want I'm pretty sure you
don't want but Democrats remember that
Rogan thing from before who's the party
of War it's Democrats so even the
governor of Michigan has to chime in and
she even admits she doesn't know what
she's talking about she has to chime in
on why we should be going to war
I'm a fellow Governor Ron DeSantis
recently made some comments or actually
he made clear this week I should say
that supporting Ukraine is not a vital
National interest to the United States
what do you say to that I am not an
expert on geopolitics but I will say
this I think it's really dangerous when
politicians are using language that is
coming out of the Kremlin there's no
question that calling it a territorial
dispute is to undermine and downplay the
Russian invasion the illegal Russian
invasion of Ukraine oh just go to war
and don't ask any questions people fund
a war forever doesn't matter how many
people get killed doesn't matter if it
wrecks our economy or anything else
somehow uh doing something halfway
across the world with no Congressional
Authority and a president who has
dementia and an endless bank account you
must support that or you're a Kremlin
operative don't you understand guys by
the way it is literally literally
everything's literal these people are so
insane that that truth is literal at
this point uh there's no metaphors with
truth it's just all literal at this
point it is a territorial dispute there
was Ukraine there was Russia they had
borders there was a separation years ago
we don't have to go into all of the
history then Russia uh jumped over the
border and sent troops in and sent tanks
and things so is it territorial dispute
they took Crimea that's a piece of
territory they did that under Obama by
the way didn't do that under Trump they
took that so there is a territorial
dispute it is a territorial dispute they
lie about everything they're they are
the party of War they are the party of
lying they are the party of chopping
your genitals off it's going to be a
hell of a DNC convention it really is
we'll chop your genitals off before we
send you to war anyway uh Gretchen
Whitmer was being interviewed there by
Jen saki she's back baby okay Jen saki
who for a year under Joe Biden when he
took office was the chief liar this was
a woman what I always say the same thing
about her if you asked her what her
color favorite color was she would say
four she cannot say anything true she
simply cannot now believe it or not
cringe I call her cringe now Corinne
Jean-Pierre cringe Jean-Pierre whoever
said that to me on Twitter thank you for
that it was a good one cringe
Jean-Pierre uh is worse which is a
miraculous thing a doctor a group of
doctors should study these people my God
we found someone who lies more than
anyone and then we found someone who
lies more than her there should be a
team of people studying them constantly
constantly now cringe gets it because
you know she's she's the diversity
choice too and Saki should have got out
of the way before that because she as
far as I could tell is a straight white
woman and you know she's an oppressor
and that whole thing okay fine saki
after lying for a year for Biden now
just got a six-figure deal to lie on
MSNBC so she has a new show she has a
new show that Whitmer interview was on
the premiere episode of the show and on
episode two uh she went off on Bethany
Mandel now you might remember Bethany
Mandel I had her as a guest a couple
weeks ago I had her
and my friend Carol Markowitz they wrote
a new book about basically about being
mothers in the woke World Bethany has
six children and as a matter of fact
when she came to Miami to to visit us so
we did the interview in person she had a
was it a one-year-old it wasn't even
Daphne was the child one even her son
was that does the son even one like the
sun was like eight months or something
like tiny tiny baby like babies that I'm
dealing with down there and she was
extremely tired uh she even said to me
before the interview I may not be that
sharp I'm extremely tired she's not
sleeping that much she's traveling she's
on a book tour blah blah blah but we did
the interview and we don't edit our
interview so it is what it is anyway she
went on a show uh on the hill nobody
watches these shows there shows there's
no benefit of doing these shows other
they're going to try other than they're
gonna try to get you it doesn't sell any
books there are some shows that sell
books you come on this show you're going
to sell some books you go on Rogan
you're going to sell some books you go
on crowder you're going to sell some
books these shows first off these Lefty
shows these people don't even know how
to read so they're just not going to buy
books anyway she went on this show the
hill and the the host asked her to
Define wokism and and she gave a pretty
banged up answer she did so you're going
to see this but here's sake going after
her and the reason I'm playing this is
the idea that saki would go after anyone
for being unsure of what they're talking
about is the height of human irony take
a look
but in a recent interview it was even
too difficult for at least one
conservative commentator to Define what
woke actually even means conservative
author Bethany Mandel has written a book
that covers this exact subject but
here's what happened when she was put on
the spot
would you mind the finding well because
it's come up a couple times I just want
to make sure we're on the same page
so
I mean woke is sort of the idea that
um
I
this is going to be one of those moments
that goes viral I mean woke is something
that's very hard to Define and we've
spent an entire chapter defining it
it is sort of the understanding that we
need to re totally reimagine and re
reduce Society in order to create
hierarchies of Oppression
um
sorry I it's hard to explain in a 15
second sound bite
it's hard to explain
it's from someone who has worked a few
years in Communications if you can't
explain it and people don't understand
it in 15 seconds it may not be the
winning message you think it is so
everyone out there it sounds like you
can let your woke flag fly
congratulations sake on your television
show by the way ease up on the makeup
you're looking a little ridiculous and a
little mannequin-like but I'll do it in
about seven seconds it's Equity over
equality through a racial and or gender
lens okay there you go I've explained
this a gajillion times everyone knows it
and I'll even throw in a little extra
got a couple extra seconds here it is
the intentional destruction of
everything that is good how about that
sake and as I tweeted out to sake this
morning I will gladly go on her show and
tell her that to her face as long as
they do it live and unedited that is the
only way that I'll do it but she is an
absolute embarrassment and and that she
then professes herself as a master of
communication Jen saki who she all she
does is suck off the system I want you
to picture the system right now I want
to picture Jen saki on her knees sucking
that system off all the time that's all
she does sorry sorry Daphne's not happy
with me on that one sorry about that one
it was a little too visual I didn't have
to do the whole visual it was should
have went a little more ephemeral on
that one Connor liked that one Daphne's
not happy okay the point is that Jen
saki would dare criticize someone for
being a bad Communicator it's almost
like there's video on the internet of
her being a bad Communicator Connor do
we have that kind of video
I can I'll Circle back if there's more I
can share with you I'll Circle back with
you if there's more to convey um I'll
have to just circle back with you we can
Circle back with I'm happy to Circle
back with you I can Circle back I will
have to Circle back on that one that's
an excellent question oh such an
important question uh we will Circle
back with you and we'll we'll Circle
back with you it's an interesting
question but uh we'll we'll Circle back
I'm happy to Circle back but I'll have
to Circle back with you on it's a good
question but we'll Circle back with you
on this today we will certainly Circle
back with you more directly I hate to
disappoint you but I will have to Circle
back with you on that
incredible communicator and you know the
thing is guys she never circles back
there was never a squaring of the circle
they would just do it again the next day
they should have oh by the way guys I
got that information for you no but see
now that was very easy for us to do
right when I said to the guys this
morning just get me something on sake
right like get me some nonsensical sake
poor communication Circle back obviously
is the line that you can get easily but
I was like could we ever find something
where jensaki said something true and
then we had to we hired 50 people this
morning we hired 50 Oompa Loompas to sit
at computers all morning could anyone
find anything of Jen saggy saying
anything true
and we finally found one clip of Jen
saki saying something true we believe
it's by accident but I will give credit
where credit is due here is Jen saki
saying something true it's a freaking
miracle
about why it's important to get
vaccinated why these vaccines are safe
why they can still kill you even if you
are under the age of 27 we need to be
clear
thank you Phoenix yes we could end the
show there but we still have to get to
the Trump stuff yeah the vaccines could
kill you she said something true it's a
miracle it was a Freudian slip but we'll
let it happen all right let's get let's
get to the Trump stuff so the big story
over the weekend is that Donald Trump on
Friday posted on Truth social that he is
going to be arrested on Tuesday the New
York Post covered it we'll just show you
the Tweet right there so it made it made
it around do we have the Tweet there
from the New York Post I think we got it
there and there's Trump with a fist to
the man Donald Trump says he will be
arrested Tuesday okay so the basics of
this story are that Donald Trump I think
in 2016 paid off former porn star uh
Stormy Daniels for some sort of
relationship that they had now a lot of
people are upset that he had some sort
of relationship with the porn star I
fairly certain Donald Trump never
pretended to be Jesus uh people bang
porn stars they pay off porn stars is
what it is let us not forget our are
good Democrat friends that Bill Clinton
once had an intern sitting on his lap
sticking a cigar in her hoo-ha while on
the phone with Trent Lott was that a
little more I feel like I said that one
in a little more of a bahua I feel like
I saw off in the blow there oh that's
funny so up in the blow
Monday guys it's Monday
so nobody's innocent is the point anyway
there is a D.A in New York City and
obviously Trump used to live in New York
City uh named Alvin Bragg and Bragg is a
Soros funded D.A and now it sounds like
he is bringing these charges up against
trump it is a state matter he is doing
this now seven years later this
obviously is set to the backdrop of
trump running for president they have
tried to get Trump on every ridiculous
little thing all of the nonsensical
impeachments in January 6th than the
Mar-A-Lago raid it's all Bs and everyone
it does I want to be very very very very
very very very clear about this it does
not matter if you like Trump if you like
DeSantis it doesn't matter if you're a
Democrat or a lefty or an atheist or a
Believer or you're green or purple
everyone should be against Banana
Republic
prosecutions by by politically motivated
DA's to stop potential political
candidates from running for office
everyone should be against this to be
clear as day and if you don't think
Hillary Clinton has done illegal things
and Bill Clinton and Barack Obama and
blah blah blah blah blah they've all
done it so if you want to end up in a
situation where we will have people get
into public office and they will all end
up in jail and we will just have this
sort of rinse and repeat situation than
you should be for this but if you don't
want that then you got to stand up
against this and I am glad to see that
many many people are standing up against
this I'm not seeing many Democrats yet
but we are seeing people say the right
thing so one of the things that was
happening all weekend I saw the hardcore
Trump people
were very angry at DeSantis because
Trump posted this on Truth social on
Friday by the way it wasn't corroborated
by anybody so this was just going off
what Trump said he has subsequently
walked it back a little bit so this may
not happen tomorrow we do not know okay
and unless there was a leak from the
office we we wouldn't know at this point
anyway I saw a whole bunch of the
hardcore Trump people saying oh DeSantis
isn't saying anything to Santa's isn't
saying anything which is just like it's
the worst version of playing politics
because this has nothing to do with
DeSantis he's not gonna you know you've
spent weeks basically the last two
months relentlessly going after DeSantis
and calling him a rhino and a globalist
blah blah blah like maybe he didn't want
to do anything anyway it was the weekend
maybe he wanted more information
literally 10 minutes before we started
the show today uh DeSantis was giving a
press conference on something else he
was asked about the Trump controversy
and here's his statement
so I've seen rumor swirl I have not seen
any facts uh yet and so I don't know
what's going to happen but I do know
this the the Manhattan district attorney
is a Soros funded prosecutor and so he
like other Soros funded prosecutors they
weaponize their office to impose a
political agenda on Society at the
expense of the rule of law and Public
Safety he has downgraded over 50 percent
of the felonies to misdemeanors he says
he doesn't want to even have jail time
for the vast vast majority of crimes and
what we've seen in Manhattan is we've
seen the sky the crime rate go up and
we've seen citizens become less safe and
so you're talking about this situation
with and like I don't know what goes
into paying hush money to a porn star to
to secure silence over some type of
alleged Affair I just I can't speak to
that
but what I can speak to
is that if you have a prosecutor
who is ignoring crimes happening every
single day in his jurisdiction and he
chooses to go back many many years ago
to try to use something about porn star
hush money payments you know that's an
example of pursuing a political agenda
and weaponizing the office and I think
that that's fundamentally wrong
that statement to me is pretty perfect
the thing that you know the laugh line
about I don't know what it's like to pay
off hush money to a pornstar okay it's
that's just funny but putting that all
aside he's right you know even the first
line he's talking about rumors swirling
here so you didn't have to jump in you
know I don't tweet on the weekends as a
general rule at least I try not to but
my feeling also is I didn't want to jump
in over the weekend because we know how
Trump uses the media we know how Trump
can be a little loose with language etc
etc so my feeling was maybe he's just
saying this to get everybody to go crazy
for three days and then it's not going
to happen well now as I said they've
subsequently walked it back a little bit
he may not be arrested and fingerprinted
and the whole thing tomorrow he's also
in Florida right now this is a New York
City D.A but the broader point on
politicizing the uh the legal system is
deeply deeply dangerous no one should be
for this if you are remotely principled
and you're on MSNBC Jan saki or Joy Reed
or anyone else stand up against this you
have a moment to do the right thing I
know it's not like in your skill set but
you might be able to do the right thing
right now you might be able to if you're
Jake Tapper over on CNN or one of these
other people to to Really uh talk about
what principles actually are
but we all know that Trump derangement
syndrome is one of the things that
breaks principles and these people
aren't very good at it uh here is uh New
Hampshire Governor Chris sununu
silencing Jake Tapper over the Trump
prosecution which he views as unfair and
unjust because he's right
I can tell you I think it's building a
lot of Sympathy for the former president
I think the fact that I was with coffee
this morning with some folks and and
there's ever not none of them were big
Trump supporters but they all said uh
you know they felt like he was being
attacked and as you pointed out this is
likely some sort of misdemeanor on an
issue seven years ago this has nothing
to do with January 6th there's folks out
there that still think this has
something to do with with January 6th so
um I just think that the the not just
the media but really A lot of the
Democrats have misplayed this in terms
of building Sympathy for the former
president and it does drastically change
the Paradigm as we go into the 24
election
dude who's absolutely right I've been a
little critical of sununu on the show
because I I think he's one of those
Republicans that can't accomplish
anything really so that's why he's put
on CNN but he did do a nice job there
Tapper looks like like he was on a
bender all night or he just can't deal
sometimes you know the thing is if you
lie all the time uh eventually it starts
bursting forth and he just looks
absolutely exhausted
um but one of the things that I often
talk about is Democrat privilege right
so if you're a Democrat you can get away
with anything you can fund the the uh
the Steele dossier if you're Hillary
Clinton and you can get away with it you
can call Trump an illegitimate president
you can get away with it you can lie
about absolutely everything because
there's an entire corporate machine
based in protecting your lives
laundering through them through the
system right we leak something to the
New York Times CNN covers the New York
Times article the thing was leaked off a
dossier that was fabricated and paid for
by a candidate but you can do all that
if you're a Democrat and get away with
it if you're a republican obviously you
can't you get these crazy Soros back
DA's going after you for as sununu said
um misdemeanor about seven years ago
right it's just all nonsense right it's
just complete nonsense but then what
happens you go on these corporate shows
and they will frame everything in a way
that of course Republicans are bad guys
and Democrats are good guys so this was
an interesting moment
I think this is ABC over the weekend
yesterday uh this is former DNC chair
Donna Brazil uh going at it with Chris
Christie over uh Alvin Bragg the D.A in
New York uh and how uh as to Chris
Christie's point this is selective in
what they go after because they'll let
criminals out on the street but they'll
go after Soros uh they'll go after Trump
for a misdemeanor that happened seven
years ago even though he doesn't live in
the state anymore they got into it
pretty good and uh done in Brazil done
in Brazil you might be thinking Donna
Brazil I haven't heard that name in a
while uh we'll tell you why after the
video
this is a party that continues to say
that they are for Law and Order when it
suits them but it doesn't suit them when
the crime is gun violence when the crime
is is seeing this country and we suffer
from the kind of violence and crime
across the board I'm not going to stand
up for that because
let me tell you who does it enforce Law
and Order when it comes to gun violence
I go into New York City every week it is
a danger zone to go into Manhattan
because Alvin Bragg is running a
revolving tour and not Prosecuting gun
crime not Prosecuting violent criminals
and if he does he lets them out within
four hours of when they're arrested to
commit more crimes so let's not get into
that argument because Alvin break has
failed miserably and all of a sudden he
wants to get but you do but you do have
a Republican
you might be wondering before we get to
the content of that why you haven't
heard the name Donna Brazil lately you
may remember we've got some info from
Politico uh what happened to Donna
Brazil Donna Brazil came to the Democrat
National Committee to steady a ship
rocked by an email hacking Scandal and
Under Fire for allegedly favoring
Hillary Clinton during the primary
process now thanks to a new email
hacking Scandal the dnc's interim chair
is at the center of a controversy of her
own with Clinton's campaign again caught
in the mix after hacked emails published
Monday by Wikileaks appeared to reveal
Brazil during her time as a CNN
commentator gave advance notice to
Clinton's Camp about debate questions
Brazil has lost a CNN contract which has
been suspended since Brazil took over
the DNC in July and found herself used
as fodder for one of Donald Trump's
favorite talking points that this is a
rigged election the D that in this
election the DNC has been in the bag for
Clinton since the beginning so you've
got to understand this Anna Brazil she
was the head of the DNC she steps down
from the DNC what happens when you step
down in shame you get a job on CNN and
then there she's giving questions to
Hillary Clinton gets caught and now she
moves to ABC This Is How They launder
the lies this is laundering the lies and
the lying Liars who lie this is it more
than anything else but speaking about
lying Liars we're on a roll let's go
back to Saki
she was in New York City for her new
show here and she must love living
amongst that filth that uh Chris
Christie's talking about and of course
by the way you guys know this Chris
Christie is a hundred percent right New
York City is a shell of its former self
people seem to be gone there seems to be
no business there everyone seems to be
up to no good the whole place smells
like weed it used to just smell like
piss now it's weed and piss it's just it
ain't good
but jensaki took a subway ride with
mayor Eric Adams Eric Adams of course
was brought in after Bill de Blasio Bill
de Blasio was a true communist I mean he
was a lunatic who destroyed 20 years of
goodness that that Rudy Giuliani and
Mike Bloomberg brought to New York City
it had a Renaissance like like never
before
I lived in New York City for most of
that it was absolutely incredible a
wonderful time to live in New York City
then de Blasio ruins it covid Etc but he
did give you a hamburger if you or you
could get a cheeseburger and fries I
think it was if you got the Kobe shot uh
but now they brought in Eric Adams
people thought oh he's better than the
Communist he isn't the whole place is a
dump but here he is with Jen sake once
again sorry Daphne on her knees as she
interviews Eric Adams on the subway
and he's a plain talking producer he has
produced you know and it's unfortunate
the noise is getting in the way of what
he has to do this has been a a president
that has navigated us at the Kobe
navigating this out of the
infrastructure Bill he's just he just
keep putting up putting points on the
board he needs to keep doing what he's
doing
but he's he is the key singer his backup
singers is to get on his
it's so I sometimes maybe we should all
just go be Democrats you guys want to
wrap up shop here it will be so much
easier on all of us where you could just
lie every what do you mean the
infrastructure Bill worked it has caused
a crazy amount of inflation on top of
the 160 billion you've given Ukraine and
he's the singer oh my God this guy's
great it's the backup singers that got
to get on board you know if you're a
real singer if you're a Tina Turner
you're out there right you're singing
the best
if the backup singers suck everyone's
pissed at Tina Turner they're not pissed
at the backup singers okay so you can't
blame the the backup singers nobody was
nobody ever left a concert like those
backup singers really sucked nobody
cares about the backup singers you care
about the person you paid for the ticket
okay but they're running cover for this
guy endlessly running cover for this guy
and why would they run cover for this
guy while at the same time having the
machine go after Trump for hush money to
a porn star seven years ago well it's
because this guy old confused
dementia-ridden hack 50-year government
hack Joe Biden with his fake teeth and
his 18 facelifts and God knows what else
they've done to him and the hair plugs
and everything else I mean he looks
scary honestly he looks scary at this
point the mumbling the fumbling the
shaking hands with air all of this stuff
well it turns out he's also a criminal
and even CNN is reporting on it
in a new memo Republicans in the house
oversight committee say three Biden
family members in 2017 received over one
million dollars indirectly from a
shanghai-based company State energy HK
limited the money came after Biden
associate John Robinson Walker received
a three million dollar wire from the
same company a transaction that was
first publicized by Senate Republicans
in 2020. Walker then transferred a third
of those funds to various Biden family
bank accounts over a three-month period
the new information uncovered by the
House GOP 35 thousand dollars in
payments to Hallie Biden Beau Biden's
Widow twenty five thousand dollars of
which was linked to the Chinese Energy
company Republicans also targeting the
president's brother James and his son
Hunter and also say they are probing an
account linked to an unknown Biden the
memo did not reveal any illegal action
by the Biden family members and the
president has long maintained he had no
involvement in any of these dealings I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period
think about what a profound lie that is
and how easily he can say it I have
never discussed with my son or my
brothers any of their business dealings
what the hell does he talk to them about
uh does anyone in here talk about work
with your family occasionally you might
mention work to the family members you
might say oh you know I work with that
Dave Rubin he keeps making these
horrible sexual jokes on a Monday
morning like it's offensive frankly
it's so insane everything they say is a
lie why else is Hunter Biden getting a
job at a Ukraine Energy company for what
was it 80 grand a month why is Halle
Biden and the brother why are they all
getting money from a Chinese Energy
company look I don't even have to lay
out the case other than if he never
discussed it with them then the family
something seriously wrong with the
family which you just have to look at
his granddaughters uh was the
granddaughter her diary was the
granddaughter's diary about showering
with Joe anyway put that aside it's just
it's too much for a Monday frankly
talking about Democrats
um
how well why else are the Chinese energy
companies pushing money to the Biden
Families how did Joe Biden become worth
millions of dollars while he was also in
service supposed to be in service of us
for 50 years like it doesn't make sense
until it does make sense but why not go
after crime right like why don't they go
after crime what they're always focused
on instead of cleaning up the cities
instead of making sure that everyone's
uh not on drugs or any of that kind of
stuff what they're always focused on is
how they can get more money for the
machine that's the ultimate launder of
the lie that is what it's really all
about as long as the Giants suck can
keep sucking they are good to go so
here's a tweet from Joe Biden over the
weekend now Joe Biden obviously does not
tweet himself there is literally zero
chance that they let Joe Biden hold the
phone you can say what you want about
Trump but it was all coming out of trump
but somebody whether it's an intern or
whoever's tweeting for Joe they try to
make it sound like it's Joe they try to
go folksy here and here's what it says
look I think you should be able to be a
billionaire but if you earn it I'm sorry
uh let's start at the top uh can you go
back a little bit phoenix look I think
you should be able to be a billionaire
if you can earn it but just pay your
fair share I think you ought to pay a
minimum tax of 25 it's about basic
fairness
guys
I'll get to Elon musk's response in just
a sec but do you see how all he wants is
more money for the machine now first off
billionaires pay crazy amount of taxes
and they pay taxes in multiple Fashions
whether it's income tax or payroll tax
or property tax etc etc they also employ
dozens hundreds thousands of people to
do all sorts of jobs and they often pay
them a lot of money to do it and they
have Yachts built and you might go well
he doesn't need that yacht and first off
it's not your business whether someone
has a yacht or not and also it costs a
lot of money to buy a yacht and then
there's a business of building yachts
and then the yacht guy can hire a whole
bunch of people engineers and people who
are going to be under the yacht fixing
things and all sorts of stuff the guy
who shines the yacht and people then
have jobs and then can pursue their
dreams but you see what Biden and the
Democrats want more than anything else
is that you will always pay more into
the system because if you always pay
more into the system somehow the Biden
family becomes pretty rich the people
who suck off the machine become pretty
rich so Elon Musk saw that Biden tweet
and he had a perfect response I paid 53
percent taxes on my Tesla stock options
40 Federal and 13 state so I must be
lifting the average I also paid more
income tax than anyone ever in the
history of Earth for 2021 and we'll do
that again in 2022 and then he tagged
Community notes that's the fact checking
thing that Twitter is laying out uh is
the three percent number cited above
accurate
look
it doesn't matter you could take all
imagine if you just said okay and this
is by the way what Elizabeth Warren and
some of the really radical nutbag
socialists want to do of the Democrat
Party if you want to tax these people 80
percent
so let's say you took Elon Musk and you
took Jeff Bezos and you took Peter Thiel
and you took 10 other billionaires and
you taxed them at 80 you took virtually
all of their wealth now the government
has all of that money do you honestly
watching this right now sitting there do
you think that anything would be done
better do you think they would do
anything better with that money do you
think anything would be run better or
any problems would be solved of course
not of course not it's the amount of
money that they have that they spend on
all of the wrong things that is the
problem so starve them that is what we
should all be doing and why else should
we be doing it because they are the ones
who are actually injecting racism they
always tell us we're the racists but
they are the ones injecting racism into
any absolutely everything every
institution it's incredible I saw this
tweet by Charlie Kirk this is this is
unbelievable he says this is the
pentagon's diversity Chief saying she's
exhausted by white folks with an ex we
are not a serious country and it's true
this woman Kalisa Wing is the pentagon's
diversity Chief so that means the
Pentagon hired someone to instill racism
within the Pentagon and here's what she
wrote a while back a while back this is
freaking a week ago I'm so exhausted at
these white folks in these PD sessions
this lady actually has the cow docity
Caucasian uh you see what she's doing
there to say that black people can be
racist too I had to stop the session and
give Karen the business we are not the
majority we don't have power uh and then
she put a threat out first off Kalisa
you're racist you are racist black
people can be racist Asian people can be
racist white people can be racist Jews
can be racist Muslims can be racist if
you judge a person based on the color of
their skin or their immutable
characteristics you basically are racist
okay I know you guys have created your
new definition of this having something
to do with power but I'm fairly certain
when you have the black supremacist
society that you want ushered in by the
Democrats uh and you're racist against
white people you're not going to call
that racism right it'll somehow be
justified uh in the name of social
justice but it's not just the race stuff
you guys know it's not just the race
stuff it's also that we must CHOP
Children's genitals off and we've got to
do it as quickly as possible here is
Rachel Levine Rachel Levine is our
Deputy Health secretary whose real name
is Richard Levine dick Levine here's I'm
sorry Daphne I'm sorry it's just it's
writing itself today it really isn't me
anyway here's dick Levine defending
child trans surgery in a speech last
week
in Ohio and
we provide expertise if you're a child
who has died you were building a
pediatric endocrinologist
is
your problems here you are being often
the same pediatric endocrinologist
Hospital who is
I think we need to work together
if we need to work together
dick Levine is just a disgusting human
being why that person wants to
chemically castrate children
they their brains are not developed
enough there's a reason you don't let
seven-year-olds Vote or seven-year-olds
drive a car but you want a
seven-year-old who might think that
they're an Autobot one day or a Jedi the
next day or Barbie the day after that
you want them to decide whether they can
literally chop their genitals off and
then what their and then with no with no
concept of how their life will be after
that now today's Brock's first day here
in the studio now that he moved to the
free state of Florida and I said to
everybody in the room who's going to
Google this for me because it's come up
before does Rachel Levine have a penis
and then I thought you know what Brock
it's your first day in the Free State
we're going to take you down a notch so
I had Brock do it and Brock is fairly
good on the computer over there and he
Googled it
you did not Google image search it right
you just Googled it straight up
he tried to Google image search it but
even he has his limits we have every
reason to believe that dick Levine still
has a wang I'm sorry I'm really sorry
um we can't do this show I can't talk
about Democrats you want me to do a
clean show we got to talk about it dick
Levine refuses to say whether he has a
wang or not but I would imagine that
dick Levine who now lives is racial
Levine if he got rid of the Wang would
be thrilled to say
there's no Wang here
so you have what you have up there is a
man dressed as a woman with a penis
telling other people's children that
they should chop their nuts off now you
might think that's a little bit odd in
and of itself but then this video came
out over the weekend this is Dick Levine
in 2019 opposing child trans surgeries
because he's happy that he has kids
but I have no regrets because if I
transitioned whether I was young and I
wouldn't have my children I can't
imagine a life without my children
and so every experience led me to here
and
um and so how could I regret that
imagine a life without my penis
it's so insane do you see that what dick
Levine wants to do is ironically take
away the choice from these children that
dick Levine himself is very thrilled
that dick Levine did Dick Levine who
lived as a man until five years ago and
had kids doesn't want kids to have that
opportunity it's in essence he's saying
this is the greatest thing ever I had
kids so I'm thrilled that I delayed it
but dick Levine with his penis is trying
to make sure that other people can't do
it
oh everyone's getting extra guacamole
today we're not even having Chipotle I'm
just ordering guacamole for everybody
because you all deserve it after this
all right here we go we're almost we're
almost done for the day people and then
and then I have to shower again I
already showered once I'm doing a double
shower day after the show
what do you do guys really joking aside
what do you do in the face of this
Insanity whether it is this gender
insanity or whether it's racist people
being put into the government or whether
it's Soros funded DA's going after the
former president do you know what you do
I can tell you what you do and I know it
is true
you just be braver walk into the fire
lead other people through and they will
follow and that is how you do it and
that is how we stop this thing there's
this guy Dave Rubin he's done a couple
videos on Prager you some people like
them some people don't I'm told he has a
wang here he did a video for prageru in
2020 that I think summed it up quite
nicely
there's a mass Affliction spreading
throughout the Western world it's called
The Bravery deficit people good people
like you are afraid to say what they
think and there's Little Wonder believe
that men can't give birth congrats
you're a transphobe want people to keep
more of what they earn because they know
how to spend it better than the
government does Bravo you're a greedy
capitalist you can't just blame
Hollywood the media and the political
establishment any longer it's time to
look in the mirror
it's time to come out of the closet the
political one you are the solution to
The Bravery deficit so what are you
waiting for
sure I'm wearing the same shirt that I
was wearing there that I needed some new
shirts Daphne new shirts
uh yeah that's the point guys just no
one's here there the calvary isn't
coming no one's here to save you you
could think Trump is Jesus too he can't
fix this alone we all have to fix it
that is the point and now I will end on
this one final thing to bring this thing
full circle a video of Tulsi gabbard
same speech that we started from uh here
she is talking about why she left the
Democrat Party and why she believes it
is so important to fight the machine
that I think I have been discussing here
for the last 68 minutes or so
but I I got to a point where I could no
longer in good conscience call myself a
Democrat because of where today's
Democratic party is
and how completely they are seeking to
undermine our freedom
when you look at the Democratic party of
today it is a party that is controlled
by this elitist cabal of War mongers
that has been and continues to be
led by the queen of War mongers herself
Hillary Clinton
it's true
not but if you think guys if you think
that Tulsi gabbard who I had on the show
you know let's say three years ago when
she was running for president as a
Democrat if you think this is where she
wanted to be I have no doubt you're
sorely mistaken now what I mean by that
is I think she wanted to be where truth
is so she's getting to that side but she
really thought that she could reform the
Democrats from the inside I asked her
about that on camera we've talked about
it off camera she thought there was a
way to make Democrats liberal again I
think Bill Maher believes there's a way
to make Democrats liberal again I it's
clear to me that Joe Rogan is finally on
the other side of that thing keep
pushing keep making sure that people
know what the truth is and know that if
just if every day you can not every day
if once a week you could get someone in
your life to just see a little more
glimmer of that truth act a little more
bravely or you can incorporate that into
your life somehow whether it's because
there's some crazy thing at your kid's
school and you're not gonna you're not
gonna stand for it or whether it's
because your company forces you you into
a Dei struggle session or whatever it is
and you push back however you can
knowing that there will be risks I'm not
telling you it's not easy but anything
worthwhile is not going to be easy right
the easy stuff is easy not the good
stuff right there's a reason for that
there's a fundamental human reason for
that and if you get in the game we can
save this thing I really believe that
that is my message for this Monday I'm
Dave Rubin with a penis signing off
join us for the post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com in about 37
seconds we leave you with a cold close
see you tomorrow
when you were singing even though I've
never lived in Ireland I I've just kept
thinking of the places that I did live
with my grandparents in Scranton when
Scranton died not died when Scranton
everything went South in Scranton we
moved to climate just as amazing what
what what what song does
[Music]